hey we've been talking about Donald
Trump's strange yet at the same time
somewhat predictable behavior and
statements during interviews lately and
it's probably not that we're noticing
this behavior from Trump during these
recent interviews because he's getting
weirder or more clueless than usual I
think it's that he did a string of
interviews after not doing interviews
for a little while and we just have more
material right now it's been sort of a
failed disgraceful shameful hundred-day
publicity tour that has completely
backfired and imploded for Donald Trump
to sum it up if you've missed maybe you
missed the Monday show or the Tuesday
show this week in one interview Donald
Trump handed copies of a map to
reporters that came to his to the OP to
the Oval Office which showed his
electoral victory and said something to
them like pretty good right he also said
very strange things about the civil war
as we talked about yesterday including
that former President Andrew Jackson
could have stopped the Civil War even
though Jackson died 16 years before the
Civil War he was totally clueless about
what was in the new Republican health
care bill claiming that quote everything
is fixed he praised multiple murderous
authoritarian figures including Kim
jong-un as a smart cookie
he had a friendly conversation with
admitted mass murderer of Filipino
president Rodrigo Duterte
during which he invited him to come to
the White House Duterte has since
rejected that invitation by the way and
most most recently Donald Trump abruptly
and awkwardly ended an interview he was
asked about those Obama wiretapped me
claims which of course we now know to be
totally bogus he didn't like being asked
about that check this out I just wanted
to find out that you're the president
United States you said he was sick and
bad because he drink anyway you can take
it any way you want but I'm asking you
because you don't want to do fake news I
want to hear this president is wrong you
don't have to ask why not because I have
my own opinions you can have your own
opinions but I want to know your
opinions you're the president a
ninth-grade it's enough thank you thank
you oh Ivy that that's that's gold right
there yeah I think at this point Donald
Trump realizes that there's downsides to
not being a politician so because he's
someone that doesn't
speak very deliberately and goes
off-the-cuff a lot right coming back to
bite him at the yeah what was presented
as this great strength of Donald Trump
is clearly not serving him super well at
least in some ways and I love that thing
where people are in being interviewed
right so the interview is to figure out
what you think and when they don't want
to answer a question they say listen it
doesn't matter what I think
you think whatever you want to think
about it well I'm interviewing you about
your opinion that's sort of why we're
here it's such a laughably flaccid
critique when they say listen doesn't
matter what I think yeah we're here
because we want to know what you think
and obviously John Bickersons opinion
does matter a little bit because he has
a show but it's not like he's in charge
of the entire federal government no it's
not like investigations using taxpayer
money might be started because John
Dickerson tweets that Obama wiretap
someone we make jokes regularly on the
show about Trump but I say this with
complete sincerity and without any trace
of cynicism at all and I know at this
point it almost sounds cliche but truly
there seems to be something
significantly psychologically and or
cognitively wrong with the President of
the United States I I don't know how
anyone can see this behavior at this
point I think this is this is a balanced
individual but the news is that
progressives aren't the only ones who
have been disturbed by Donald Trump's
recent round of interviews White House
officials have said that these this
string of interviews that Donald Trump
did around the hundred day mark it
didn't represent some broader strategy
like from the outside we saw oh he's
doing a Reuters interview and all these
different interviews this must be part
of some plan to do something and White
House officials are saying no it wasn't
actually part of some broader plan maybe
they're lying because it didn't go well
maybe initially it was part of a broader
plan and now they're saying that because
it didn't really go well but the key
point is that White House staffers are
realizing that Donald Trump is coming
off like a total lunatic here one
a White House staffer who spoke on the
condition of anonymity said the
interviews were not helpful to us there
was no point
to do all of them now that I do buy
because this has not gone well for the
administration Trump's failures have
heavily outweighed his accomplishment he
doesn't know what he's doing and the
interviews have certainly not helped
anything at all
uh but one Republican staffer went even
further pat and said he just seemed to
go crazy and again I don't think that
Trump actually just went crazy I think
it's that the fact that he chose to do a
string of interviews just exposed how
unbalanced he is it also seems like he
bought into the idea that the first 100
days is incredibly important and he
didn't have to do that I mean that's
kind of an arbitrary measure yeah but he
seems to have taken a drink from the
kool-aid he initially said the hundred
days were going to accomplish all this
stuff and then as we were getting to the
end of the hundred days he sort of
backed off of it and said hundred days I
mean who you know 100 days I'm here for
years hundred days doesn't really even
matter that much so yeah you're it's one
of these self-inflicted wounds where
he's the one who initially talked about
everything he was going to accomplish in
the first hundred days it imploded
multiple I mean just countless failures
which I won't even list for you right
now
and now the staffers are noticing like
hey this guy's coming off like the
madman that he is and these interviews
are a really bad idea